[Music]
this week we've got Asian rage
predicable thieves and shocking
livestream I like all three of these
there's no such thing as Asian rage
that's a myth it's just it's uh it's we
got it's just Asian true what is this
agent rage it's just Asia it's just us
being us yeah oh my god hate being angry
me too awks
makes you look old I don't know like
your back gives out it's exhausting dude
yeah dude ruins your whole day week [ __ ]
it makes you sad get a sore throat or
screaming so much I know that should
have been that lovers have you been have
you guys ever seen like a public like
someone you actually know like have you
guys ever seen like a public rage like
something just rage out like crazy
I seen a dude yell at his girlfriend
I've seen myself do that many times in
public yeah a nice cool time because now
I'm at you doing dad throw vegetables at
his son oh well we were all eating
hotpot
at the little fat sheep well and I was
gonna smack his dad and I was like okay
he stopped oh yeah he grabbed a plate of
vegetables and he [ __ ] chucked it at
his kid how old is good he was like six
or seven or so all of us looked over and
then I was with my very bad friends and
use like I just [ __ ] that fool up I
like I'm all like hey just just chill
we're eating and then they just thought
that whatever there's not even because
like for morals it's just you're just
looking for a reason to fight that's
probably he's just probably angry that
kid's gonna be scarred for the rest of
his life he's never let us again you
[ __ ] yeah yeah or bok choy and the
Japanese pumpkin and I know
you could never look at Napa ever I was
in Koreatown at a coffee shop and like
there was a table next to me it was like
one old Korean guy and like three
younger ones and [ __ ] I wish you were
there or something the times you can
translate because this is the old guys
sounded pissed like you were so mad what
if he's just talking like normal Korean
and then he turned around he slapped
their [ __ ] out of one of everything the
young one just sat there like this I
wonder what that kid did right like I
want to know what happened I'm so
curious because I am I can remember my
dad doing [ __ ] like that to me yeah
however it was well deserved I'm
thinking like what the [ __ ] did you do
like but the only all the guys sitting
with him look the same age like young
maybe like in their 20s so they I don't
know like if they're brothers and they
worked for him it was a [ __ ] mafia
meeting in the middle of a coffee shop I
don't know it was probably like
something that happened yeah turn it
like stupid or whatever like you you
make me look stupid yeah yeah that could
possibly be so what's going on with this
let's bring back some [ __ ] haunting
memories what's this Asian rage thing in
your face you know let's talk about some
depressing ass [ __ ] childhood scars
[ __ ] well I mean this might make you
laugh so this guy from China China so he
was notified that his car was being
towed and so he was fine and simple at
first like when he first got there but
then that's okay hakuna matata he found
when he found a hammer and he started
destroying his cart why would his old
car the own cart why take it take it
look like [ __ ] what happened he has to
go to the tow truck place pay for it and
then get it out now he's driving off
with the holy car yeah so apparently
this dude had more than 240 tickets
under his name for traffic violations oh
yeah we Chinese person so he owed more
than five thousand or about five
thousand seven hundred dollars in unpaid
fines and so he was just like you know
what [ __ ] this you guys are taking my
car no one else can use it so he
destroyed his own car I think weren't
gonna use it
any without a Mercedes or the Chinese
Mercedes it's a fake Mercedes yeah and
this is him destroying his car must have
a chance why did I make everything fake
over there they're not impounding it so
they can use it and take it for joyrides
they're impounding it until you come get
it so I don't understand his luck she's
a [ __ ] lunatic when you might be
getting repo'd either why you start to
pay the ticket gonna do it sometimes
when you get angry you just you don't
know what the [ __ ] you do you don't know
where did he get that hammer like did he
run into a hardware store real quick
yeah he found it's just interesting like
remember we did another [ __ ] weekend
Scrabble word in in Florida the guy just
came out with a hammer and started
smashing that [ __ ] hitting one driver
oh yeah this is super mario brothers a
shoe you carry like a bat or something
in your car no really you lose too but
not anymore than this time I have morals
I keep a knife in the glove yeah but
that's in case you need to cut your
seatbelt yep yeah or somebody's but you
can't even move if your seatbelt stuck
you can't even reach the you don't know
that it's sorry not the glove the center
console yeah that's in case for carson's
and you need to cut your seatbelt yeah
that's why you need the knife four small
fingers and also this dude he after you
destroyed his car he just ran away
but the police finally were able to
detain him and they held him for ten
days I mean the cars under your name
yeah I did it's not very difficult to
know who did that one of the single
owner of a Mercedes Chen's
person here no that's why he bought a
Mercedes Chen it's like when I used to
get angry I used to always break my
phone that didn't do anything but caused
me grief
yep it was the dumbest [ __ ] thing I
kept on doing and it was very expensive
to replace those phones yeah sometimes
you have to break things you care about
in order to satisfy the breaking mmm-hmm
you know what I mean
because you can't because people always
say like once you put your pillow it's
not the same
say I have to take my phone and crush it
into smithereens why your phone why not
something else because you want to do it
to someone's skull but you can't thank
you thank you watermelons
how do you do school make sure you read
you now I haven't been met or what's the
craziest thing you've done when you oh
yeah are you know about this I took a
golf club two walls and mirrors oh
that's very good nummies of you yeah cuz
he cheated on me very very easy that's
also a country music video before he G
yeah what's her name she's smashing up a
car it's not Shania to me Shania Twain
no she's not its wine no you know Shania
Twain then [ __ ] Dolly Parton's but I
know I know that song though I know that
[ __ ] country song is dope I don't get
angry anymore I kind of just like I like
the last time I got angry was that
[ __ ] dumbass dude that threatened to
hit me when I was dating him so instead
of getting angry I just ditched him in
the middle the road because you're not
in love I ditched him in the middle of
the road in a road trip in Arizona and
he had no money at home if they don't
make you feel like you want to bite them
then it's not I think the worst thing
I've ever done was like slap the dude
cause he pissed me off that's amazing I
wanted that's bad yeah then I never I
never yell either when I'm angry but
well you don't yell period screaming at
the top of my lungs
it was so therapeutic and after I was
like even back you could double
Wow dude that shit's [ __ ] classiest
Wow
I think the first lap would have been
like that's hard too because like one
sees laughs and once they kind of back
out like so does done they're stun doing
you just keep going give a stepstool ha
ha no you know the finding is you know
what you know what uh what in the
comments right now there's gonna be some
little [ __ ] says if this was a guy
doing it to a girl you guys wouldn't be
laughing his hard that's true because
the [ __ ] damage that we caused his
worse all that tip slap me all day but
if I you know yeah it's not the same
that guy has terrible head movement Bart
Bart said that I slept and backhanded
geo the comments would go [ __ ] nuts
I don't think so they'd be like she's
built for it Amazonian that's true
that's true he would have to get on
steps little to that fool need a booster
seat Jess we can reach GE like the
old-school boxing games you remember
these little back on punch-out use
Little Mac he has a job to [ __ ] punch
Mike Tyson gah go fight through this
thing go back go back go back
alright now punch me What's it feel like
to get slapped in the face
my mom would slap me in the face all the
time my mom slapped my dad in the face
and I cried I was like dude
[Music]
yeah yeah like there are getting in the
car and then I was in the back and then
she smacked him in the face and I was
like don't fight why is this so much
fighting if they stopped did you guys
ever get to see the moment your viewer
your your parents whatever really they
can teach you anymore did you guys know
cuz they still it was like 17 17 that's
it last year when I was about like 14 my
grandma slapped me and I went and then
shoes what and I just never heard oh my
god you're [ __ ] sure they just here
that's elastic oh [ __ ] yeah every yeah I
have Julie cheeks oh and then like from
that moment on she realized she can
never hit me again yeah I don't know my
mom still hits me till this day
and I should [ __ ] a hurts man well
yeah she's [ __ ] strong as [ __ ] it
doesn't matter how weak you are if you
have a weapon or weapons ouch it's the
only thing we should be hitting is that
[ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay the next story so the next story
here we have these these thieves who
were robbing a Seattle area Costco
oh I seen this video it's gay it's so
awesome because the cops already so he
had gotten a call from the Costco
employees because they recognized the
same I know so you never had a place
twice he recognized the guy and he said
like yeah he came recently and they
stole a little bunch of stuff and he ran
out through the exit so he told the cops
this information so the cops were all by
the exit and they saw the getaway driver
this 18 year old girl and zoom in so I
will show you babe the body cam footage
did it have guns
no the bad guys Walker and and then as
we get out I love how they have so much
time to set it up with the camera and
everything
[Music]
the first tried to make off with laptops
and a fuse and are suspected of stealing
similar items from another Costco in
this Seattle oh my god yep what was
their car parked out there - yeah the
getaway driver and they they had just
that same day they hit up another Costco
oh so reckless dude why do you want to
take from Costco it's already cheap at
Costco hmm that's [ __ ] up man it's
like stealing at the dollar store
I wouldn't help well no I guess they
were watching here cuz they blocked in
the driver cuz then if I were here I
would just text my friends like you
don't you just leave but that but they
probably their hands were full they
probably grabbed her oh yeah she might
have sent the text on they just can read
it I'm pretty sure if I got caught doing
that stuff I wouldn't ever I just laughs
I'm like you got me I wish they didn't
blur their face because I I want to see
the reaction so them pretty sure was
like yeah they're criminals why blur
their face out understand blurring their
face until they're proven guilty but
that like yield alt guilty you know if I
was caught with crimes I would be like
why did you blur it man the world needs
to know the world is to know who are you
to be infamous have you guys ever ran
from the cops before yes yes I wish they
would have time me that was literally
like the fastest I've ever ran in my
entire life did you get they were just
like oh and a [ __ ]
he was waiting I was hopping like the I
Amelie ran to residential neighborhood
and in the backyard of houses I was
hopping a backyard backyard backyard
backyard and that fat [ __ ]
couldn't just couldn't clear with all
his gear he just couldn't clean I was
smart I never ran from [ __ ]
I just dropped there's no point you
reach in the back of the cops just take
because what happens is is if you run I
end up being tired sweaty and I know for
a fact he's gonna catch me
so at this point I just drop it's like
what's the point man and you don't get
charged for avoiding arrest yeah it's
fantastic
and plus they appreciate me because I
didn't run true should be thank you
yeah I feel like thanks for not running
I said come on bro look at me awake
closet family
[Laughter]
like that like the only time it happened
is like when we did like this at school
somebody basically had to take a [ __ ]
they [ __ ] went into the the teachers
lounge they have a door passcode
triggered a silent alarm cops came and
then dude man you and I never knew how
fast my cook my friends could run their
[ __ ] quick I am NOT fast like this
dude he was like men
this [ __ ] said like what do we
do we just see this cool a dot in the
distance do you still wear that [ __ ] you
know the those shoes that had to elevate
a front that was strengthen your calves
all the jumps all's he wore that [ __ ]
every day to school he knew he was gonna
run he was all about speed and jumping
at the time so he was trying to dunk and
[ __ ] but damn he was [ __ ] quick so
fast no but they were pretty rough with
you back in the day they literally would
call us they were calling us yeah it's
like all this other stuff like literally
grab this [ __ ] slammed us see [ __ ]
like that so it's not very pleasant it's
not like now where it's just like hey
what are you guys doing it was like it
the [ __ ] on before you it was a crazy
[ __ ] yeah I remember recently we were in
high school during this time but there
was a bomb threat and it was all over
the news and all the kids at mark temple
high school were like man the cops were
so [ __ ] me because they put them all
into the auditorium and in there killer
there tell him killing oh my god no they
were telling them [ __ ] like like look
at look the other way with your Chinese
eyes or some other [ __ ] like that and
it's like why do you have a camera so
it's all Chinese cops - [ __ ] man
all right for a last story there is this
Latvian artists Latvia Latvia where is
that it's right next to Estonia where is
that it's in between Roman Poland and
Russia Lithuania Lithuania yes no this
artist he was live streaming and he was
doing this performance art and a lot of
people had a problem with this he was
jacking off into a grapefruit know what
he did was that really stuck with David
well that was literally what happened
with the bodybuilder yeah yeah but it
stuck
they've had but it's a funny video done
funniest videos I've ever seen the whole
purpose of this performance was to
highlight what would happen to humanity
if global food sources ran out so what
he did is he had these two models stand
there and he like we don't know if this
was real or simulated or like staged and
so that's why police are now
investigating this but he pretty much
like he cut flesh off of these people
fried it in a frying pan in front of
them and then fed that to them also we
don't know if it's real or if it's fake
quality screaming could be makeup fake
[ __ ] it could be so police are
investigating here you what is it
cutting the salt or something that's
nasty I don't need this guy to see this
[ __ ] I don't get it ah
[Music]
good they are with makeup this is a whip
noises it [ __ ] the breaking glass that's
so weird
I don't get it I can't imagine eating my
own [ __ ] like we're like we're killing
ourselves and cannibalizing ourselves
and bloody liver bladder this
that's so [ __ ] wack I could just
watch an episode of Walking Dead yeah
what's that one serial killer movie when
he cuts his brain I mean I can see why
people got all crazy about it but it can
also be fakers [ __ ] - it's pretty wack
though well I'm glad they're investing
not even next-level [ __ ] if it is real
and I was that modelling you better be
paying me a [ __ ] ton of money
mmhmm yeah but that artists I mean he's
an interesting artist his name is
artists berzins artist person oh my god
artist 1 that's his [ __ ] name artist
person he's trying to get out of out of
trouble what's your name I don't
understand art like this he also does
like visual I was like visual he also
does like paintings and Kai check out
his website and he then directed this
music video for cradle if it fails so
it's like Hello a lot of it is just it's
it's one note it's one of motion which
is cringe so a lot of contemporary or
all that stuff is just one note it's
kind of like it's not anything shocking
to me it's just everything is just barf
it's one feeling there's nothing new
it's just like let me [ __ ] vomit on
the floor and that's [ __ ] modern
society I like art like I have like a
limit to art like there's like paintings
a little bubble of but the music this
one threshold right here that when he
gets
that I'm like alright bring it back like
you know the it's like a what is it like
a super intense art students and then
moving forward
like like the weird the weird art
installations that make no [ __ ] sense
whatsoever it's like alright you need to
bring it back a little bit you're a
little bit too passionate and it breeds
me the [ __ ] out I just don't get it yeah
it's because it's OneNote and it's just
an extreme emotion so it's like one note
of shock one note of disgusting one note
of gross and it's like wow you're so
revolutionary there's like I think like
they blur the lines between this is
super artistic - dude this is [ __ ]
dumb like you're doing way too much
right now and they just don't understand
the difference between that I just feel
stupid because I'm just like have I not
consumed enough art to where I'm like
this is [ __ ] weird all the [ __ ]
going on I don't give a [ __ ] because I
have seen stuff thanks to the internet
surface where I think you guys probably
seen it - it's like the sky white room
he has like unflushed colored underwear
on there's like we like this thing in
the stick like he's hitting the meadow
and I'm like maybe I just haven't
consumed it a fart know this shit's
weird as [ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ] it's
equivalent to people on the internet
that are fake look like you're too fake
artistic like calm down you know I just
hate pretentious [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] so
the best and so underground and it's so
exclusive and they have like their black
like fedora this is real and the realist
art and nobody can understand it's not
yeah the black glasses [ __ ] that
[Music]